good morning good morning good morning
everybody welcome back for gratitude
journal time it's gratitude journal time
its nine a.m. eastern at least super
excited to be back this is number 14
number for that means number nine on the
new channel nine how many did we do in
the first channel I think was 31 in the
first channel yes number nine on the
second channel I love it guys so we do
this every day every weekday at least I
hope you're doing it every day sharing
things you're grateful for thinking
about it reflecting on it you could join
me on these live chats I'm going to
share three things I'm grateful for I
want you to put yours in the live chat
people watching afterwards put it down
the comments below it's important that
you're consistent with it you can deal
with me you can do it on your own just
do it just do it just do it because we
need happier healthier entrepreneurs go
make a positive impact on this world and
then the next step is just making sure
again that you think about it think
about why reflect on it take a couple
seconds why this is so important to you
so I'm going to go first and then we'll
get to the live chat and see you guys
have to say I am grateful for my
ungrateful for my co-collaborators today
I'm going to go on a it's a
codecollaborator theme of the day today
and it was inspired by J reyez who's
actually in the room with me here well
so we'll see if we make him blush or not
as we say some things but this inspired
the list so yesterday I put out a video
of Justin Bieber's top ten rules for
success and this this might be more work
that I put in the entire reefs which is
crazy I think I watched every single
Justin Bieber interview a hit from his
new stuff and I knew there'd be a lot of
hate and I wanted to you know Justin
Bieber is a symbol Elise is a symbol for
me of somebody who can rub a lot of
people the long way but
you could still learn from him and so I
really wanted to make sure that the
video had some good stuff in there that
people could learn from and get inspired
by and so I put it insane amount of work
into it we put it up last night and it
got a lot of love and I got a lot of
hate I think the ratio of like likes to
dislikes are our yeah that pretty equal
where most of my videos is going to be
like ninety-five percent lights and so I
got home from a meeting last night the
Toronto dance salsa I'd like 10 10 40
ish or something at night and I went in
to look at all the comments and I was
all set to there was one comment that
really bothered me and I was all set to
like rip in to get all passionate and
excited and and fight and fight because
we know one thing that just really
bothers me is is uh untapped potential
and seeing these you know some of these
people the closed mindedness I just
really bothers me he's holding
themselves back and then perpetuates the
cycle and so I was about to I was about
to rip in on this comment and then I saw
one of jay's comments above or below I
guess it was below um and it was another
guy who was hating and in Jays initial
response was just like wishing you open
mindedness and thoughtfulness and
abundance or something like that like
all positive intentions like huh that's
a interesting way to handle the
situation that was interesting way to
handle situation Jay you haven't happy
have in front of you what did you say
what were the exact words wishing you
and improved attitude outlook
perspective and appreciation there you
go wishing you an improved attitude
outlook respect respect and appreciation
I really like that I really like that
comment so uh
so I got inspired and decided that I
would change my approach on how I
handled the camera that I really
disagreed with though everything along
the same same lines I I didn't use the
same words but you know along the same
lines as so anyway I felt good about
that and then that was thinking of my
feeling grateful for Jay last night I
thought you know I got to bring it to
the live stream today so thank you for
the middle of their uh so while i'm on a
Nicole contributor you know vibe I
thought I would continue this on for the
live stream today I want to thank Rishi
I'm grant I'm grateful for Rishi for the
energy she brings to the League of
Legends chat that we do daily a positive
attitude and her caring in the questions
and how much she's grown from when we
started in the end the love that she has
and all the great kind of follow ups
thoughts that she has in the you know
cool to the day and summarizing thought
at the end I'm a big fan and super
appreciative and then number three my
third collaborator on the League of
Legends chat was jen and she only came
in for one day but but she's super
subbed in and then she did really well
and somebody commented so all the people
who ask us questions we write back to
them and say hey we entered your
question on the lives on the live stream
and they going back and watch it and jen
after her first day had somebody comment
thank you so much Evan and Jen you know
I really appreciate your answer really
meant a lot to me so I forwarded that to
her too did let her know hey like the
only one episode in here he had an
impact there too so it's a kid a really
great job and I'm I'm grateful for her
stepping in and stepping up and us
having a good time on that one day so
I'm grateful for all of my
co-collaborators on all the different
projects that I've been working on and
want to highlight three of them today
with you guys let's get to the live chat
and see what you guys have going on what
you're grateful for pop it into the chat
we'll do some shoutouts Zeno started us
off again hey you what do you mean
before today I like that I like that
Cena Zeno's game football one ice cream
for being yummy I go for some ice cream
right now like a dairy queen smash
what's the smash like cookie smash
peanut butter smash something hmm okay I
got it I gotta have my my celery here so
I'm not as hungry anymore I like legit
have seller is my breakfast I have
celery with peanut butter or almond
butter i think it's peanut butter
cheering fry screaming you should have
heard your voice drop for you okay so
listen salaries yeah celery whoo number
two they sell you my breakfast water I
love it too for its large amount of uses
it's pretty cute waters useful in a lot
of different things and three mine and a
lot of people's BFF Google I love that
Google is pretty resourceful God ji is
thankful for conscious body control for
anyone focus on health and well-being
love that for firm what what does that
mean One Nights maimonides eight levels
of giving what is that I'm sure it's a
Jewish like philosophy and they have
eight levels of giving a TG to kids like
there's ways to give but there's better
ways to do and like it's a nice next
level man all right let's go to go to
look that up I'm gonna copy and paste
that into Google guys my BFF insane
those two to six figure out what that is
after this chat and end after the league
of legends live stream hmm what else jri
sharing the justin bieber top 10 thanks
for that what else we got what else we
got widows
got Z no I'm not a fan of the beep stir
maybe after I've watched the top 10 but
have no reason to hate the guy let that
sky's the limit great rising people
beautiful people I love it always loved
the energy from sky's the limit o 9
grieve over believe nation love it
sunrises I was thinking that too man
like the Sun is rising later now uh and
it's so beautiful to look out man just
like the warm glow pouring through my
condo in the morning i love it and open
minded people under percent 100% sky's
the limit Sarah good morning I'm
grateful for watching the sunrise this
morning got a lot of sunrise love and
the chat we put for this gratitude
journal because it's a daily reminder
for me to be grateful me too one percent
and Griffin for the local bakery in town
I love that what do you get at the local
bakery I'm curious I'm like I'm a hunger
I'm hungry can you guys tell him hungry
today I'm hungry when I scream I want
bakery big goods I have my I have a tea
that J reyez brought me I gotta dig into
peach peach tranquility oh it smells
good it's not really good like that
Andrew good morning grieving for number
one Deeley strained of Mental Floss
given to me each day from Evans channel
I love that number two was mom's text
this morning wanting to watch Sun
tomorrow giving wife and I a date night
very cool and three endless
opportunities each day very cool guys
nine ten that's it ten minutes goes
quickly thank you so much for joining me
we're going to hop over to twitch play a
game of League of Legends while we
answer your business questions hopefully
see you there if not have an amazing day
I hope you go off and do something
special with your company today you know
you owe to yourself to do something
pretty special today so get your I'm
special hat on and go do something
amazing thank you guys for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon